when I was about six or seven years old
I was flipping channels on the
television it was Monday Night Raw the
very first thing I see Jeff Jarrett
guitar over someone said I don't know
who was six-year-old holy SH that's what
I want to do
[Music]
my name is he son Lee and I'm a rapper
people come up to me you know they'll be
like wow why are you not huge
[Music]
rid of this there's my matchup tonight
the 1% Terrell Nelson and Royce Isaac's
it will never hurt you to look better so
when I come to nutrition has been so
much freaking money on food I live by
myself and it's sink it's filled with
dishes like on a daily basis Sam I just
need to know for sure what's aren't
gonna be here I'm thinking two o'clock
I'm at acting partner his name is Royce
Isaac's you and I go by the 1% which is
the whole idea behind the name is that
we look better than 99% of the rest of
the world
[Music]
I've always told myself I'm gonna do
music very hard I'm an independent
artist you have this voice and you want
to shout that your life in this room and
nobody hears you you know sometimes I'm
eating with my friends and even my
family members and I'm just like what do
I talk about they all like also she's
just doing that and I'm just like yeah
I'm something you know I'm doing an
album I was going on for adoption my
parents didn't name me so I was put into
a foster home based off of my adoption
papers my foster mother named me he son
I got into church a lot and I was
praying a lot my mom was getting worried
you know and a lot of it was my identity
issues professional wrestling if you
break it down to the ground level it's
it's heroes versus villains for the most
part wrestling's all about the moments
that you can create if you can get the
fans to invest in those moments I am a
bad guy 100 percent in real life fairly
wrestling I've been doing this since I
was like 17
I saw Will Smith on camera and I'm like
oh my gosh she's cute so then I would
just follow his life and then I started
liking hip-hop because of that just
check her sofa
it's enough of that
to find some food man there's a reason
why by Dave's killer bread and bagels 11
grams of protein and per bagel 49 grams
of carbs peanut butter that's what I
made
gotta go the natural I don't know why
you know I'm a check that's all right
now how about there's not even a single
thing different with this nope that's
how you know there ain't [ __ ] different
with this we're in Jersey right now and
I have a show in Maryland it's for the
first lady of Maryland and it's actually
like a cultural celebration for arm for
adoptees I'm assuming she's gonna give
me the check today for my my honor area
but because it's like the governor you
know there's a lot of things that come
into play I think
[Music]
yeah it's anything I was calculating it
recently if I do all of the songs that I
you know six songs it costs roughly
around like almost seven thousand for
just reporting and to do the promotion's
music videos photoshoots this EP would
probably cost almost 15,000 everything
cost money and even if it sometimes it's
just 80 bucks here two hundred dollars
there you turn around and you spend
almost a thousand dollars
[Music]
do you know how much of banana cos well
in Los Angeles way too much
and Washington stay away from like 17
cents of Pompano but now I don't I
didn't tell you like I know for sure how
much of Samsung Galaxy S nine the tops
if I bought it outright that's like 600
700 dollars so you just ask me how much
banana toss that I eat every day how
much how I gotta get Burger King holster
it's the cheapest
[Music]
second when you go on these these road
trips and stuff it's kind of hard
because I love his beautiful right now
[Music]
you bet I will
my wrestling boots this is our gold pair
1% this one's falling apart though
there's our purple one these cost us $50
a pair so $150 right there worth the
rest of them gear our checking account
will go really low and I'm like okay Tim
you can't take any money out for the
next two weeks you know I'm not blaming
Tim because he has a great job he works
really hard
[Music]
I try to get some overtime and they I
give you to get some extra money to help
with funding for music videos social
media yo you might need to get a job and
then I'm thinking but I can't get a job
because I'm taking care of my two kids
and if I take care if I get a job I
gotta put one of them in daycare and
that kind of like would totally just X
out my paycheck anyway this is for later
but if you want the big I'd just feel
like later on I might need that little
extra kick
have you had your daily coq10 well if
you drank this you would you guys all
know how much my each other making
tonight I know how much voice is making
cuz I set up the booking Royce and I
agreed on a hundred each so you make it
a hundred I'll make it 120 do you guys
feel that you're compensated
appropriately for like the work that you
put your bodies through us we put hard
work we're on the road a lot with just
driving up late nights early mornings
even the most basic simple wrestling
move you can lose your life if you
compare even like what we get can pay
paid compared to like stuntmen and stuff
like that where they're in a controlled
environment there's multiple takes
there's padding there's harnesses
whatever like now we're just like out
there everyone involved in wrestling
should be getting paid more yeah
absolutely
yeah
[Music]
I've been worthless on like a bunch but
maybe don't throw punches in your mouth
[Music]
if you stand up
do I base my success off of am i selling
out stadiums am I going on tours I saw
like a lot of adoptive parents they were
smiling when I was up there and
hopefully when I meet with them later
they're gonna say wow like you're like
inspiring it's a roller coaster what
would you when we take people through an
emotional journey with physical impact
of storytelling and great character work
I may not have made a million dollars
today or not a million but I may go home
and still struggle with money I may
still wonder when my next show is gonna
be but when I do get that show and you
get those people coming up to you you
know that's why you kind of do it we're
always beat up after this and then a lot
of us are gonna sit in cars and drive
however many miles will we wake up with
pain of course but do we love it hell
yeah
I knew I'd yeah thank you thank you
thank you you guys aren't on Instagram
are you are you so maybe if your kids
want to learn to hip hop you know they
could listen to it it's a great day
today I love doing shows like this you
kind of don't know what to expect I got
people jumping and sharing and having a
great time and you just would never
expect to see certain people doing that
especially to hip-hop so boy worked
harder than anyone you know back to the
grind doing what I do make a music
performing and you know it's kind of
like a hippie Pete you keep doing this
and keep okay for the best
[Music]
for 30 this is the most expensive part
I've ever been to my I didn't even get
up acceptance I didn't even get a full
tank nine gallons nine gal I'm triggered
you're very true I've been shut good
wings I've been railroaded Buffalo